now that's fine man homecomings Home
Entertainment releases ours there's a
stack of bonus material including new
deleted scenes with footage
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing some very cool
spider-man homecoming deleted scenes and
explaining some of the Easter eggs and
missing details we never got to see in
the theatrical release I'm also starting
a new Funko pop giveaway on this video
and for a chance to win make sure you're
subscribed to my channel and leave a
comment below with your thoughts on the
deleted scenes or and I think marble
quick warning obviously there are
spoilers ahead for anyone who's not seen
the movie yet
the first deleted scene on the digital
release comes via an extended director's
cut of Peter Parker's vlog style behind
the scenes video of what happened on his
trip to Berlin during the events of
Captain America Civil War the extended
version includes some great additional
footage of what Peter got up to the
night after the airport battle in Berlin
when he was so hyped up that he decided
to put on his Spidey suit and go
partying in the German capital
this additional footage of spider-man
swinging between buildings with a girl
explained set photos it emerged during
the movies production which showed
spider-man swinging from a helicopter as
he looked to be saving a redheaded girl
which at the time led to some
speculation that Mary Jane was going to
appear in the movie the extra footage
also seems like a fun way for the movie
to pay homage to the web slinging
superhero from Sam Raimi's trilogy who
swung between New York skyscrapers with
ease which was something the filmmakers
otherwise made a conscious decision to
step away from in homecoming and that
might be the reason this scene ended up
being deleted because Tom Hollands
spider-man in both Civil War and Home
Coming hasn't yet mastered all his
abilities and actually finds it pretty
scary when he has to scale the
Washington Monument so including scenes
of him happily swinging through Berlin
might have felt inconsistent with his
character at this point it's still a
shame we couldn't see this cut though as
it also finishes with a funny scene
where Peter gets busted by happy hogan
who discovered what he got up to thanks
to the front pages of a german newspaper
and that feels like a nice way to end
the scene especially given that the
filmmakers set up pieces vlog as an
updated take on his photojournalism in
the comics and previous movies after the
school bus leaves for the academic
decathlon it passes by a road sign that
reads for skelion clean up a little
Easter Egg - the shield headquarters
located on Theodore Roosevelt Island in
Washington DC
the building was severely damaged during
the final showdown between Hydra and
shield in Captain America the Winter
Soldier and as a deleted scene in
homecoming which revisits the damaged
site in the scene peter ned and michelle
see the damage Triskelion building as
the school bus drives over a bridge
damage control they're still cleaning up
for when Captain America took down the
sky crab carriers for no reason I'm
pretty sure that was just for the sails
from tearing that that's what don't want
you think it's a humorous moment that
shows how different characters in the
MCU view Captain America now to thinks
he's a hero but Michelle is way more
skeptical this would have been an
interesting Easter Egg to include but it
looks like it was likely cut for time
which will also saved a little cash as a
CGI for the damage to a scallion
building wasn't completed by the way the
scene also included a little joke about
Thor not having a phone a nice nod to
the funny moment in the Thor
mockumentary worth or complains to Bruce
Banner about Tony Stark and Captain
America not asking him to help out with
Civil War
no yeah talk to Thor yeah he's sort of
been waiting here from you I have him
right here oh you can't right now you
guys know how to get in touch with you I
don't I don't have a phone he doesn't
have a phone send a raven home coming
already keys the existence of Miles
Morales in the MCU in the scene where
Donald delivers character Aaron Davis
gets caught by Spidey in a car park and
mentions he has a nephew in the
neighborhood but there's a little extra
footage of Donald Glover that makes the
existence of Miles Morales even clearer
excuse me a human being needs help
yeah sorry miles I'm I'm not gonna make
it yeah I'm just ugh if this moment was
indeed meant to complete the movie scene
with Glover I can see why it was Kurt as
it slows down the film cementum just for
the sake of making a more obvious
reference to Miles Morales however I
wonder if it might have originally been
planned as a humorous extra post or
mid-credits scene in the comics Davis is
the uncle of Miles Morales who like
Peter Parker was bitten by a radioactive
spider turning him into a famous web
crawling superhero Miles Morales will be
getting his own animated spider-man
movie released by Sony however the
Morales Easter Egg and Home Coming could
also be setting up a possible appearance
in the MCU somewhere down the line
talking of possible deleted after
credits scenes
it looks like the vultures mid-credits
scene was cut back as laura harrier who
played Adrian Toomes as daughter Liz has
revealed that she filmed a scene where
she meets her father in prison if you
noticed the mid-credits scene actually
finished with a prison guard calling out
to the vulture that his family had
arrived to see him
this is interesting because Harrier has
said she wishes a scene had been
included and she's also said that she'd
like to see her character Liz get powers
as she does in the Ultimate Comics as a
superhero Firestar
in fact I wonder whether that additional
moments in the mid-credits scene could
have set that up in some way it was only
a little bit of footage from the Midtown
high school news channel in the final
cut of homecoming this past weekend
Midtown's academic decathlon team
defeated the country's best to win the
national championship later that day
they also defeated death as you know we
made it out alive and that's the
important thing
I couldn't bear to lose a student on a
school trip not again but there's a load
more additional news footage with Betty
and Jason that we never got to see it's
got plenty more hilariously awkward
lines and deliberately bad editing but
interesting they also include some
Easter eggs and additional info on small
plot points from the movie questions
remain this morning as authorities piece
together the alarming events at this
weekend's homecoming dance an
unidentified male individual assailant
was taken into custody after police
found him attached to the side of a bus
with spider-man webs okay to those of
you who love you who took inappropriate
selfies with the perpetrator web to the
bus you have 24 hours to remove them
from all of your social media accounts
at the end of that clip we can see that
tiny one of Peters classmates is now in
possession of shockers gauntlet which it
looks like he nabbed from the villain
after spider-man webs shocker to school
bus during their fight in the movie this
moment could just be a bit of fun
or it might he is Tiny's character
actually using this high-tech weapon in
the sequel especially given that in the
comics tiny has been known to bully
Peter the girls basketball team takes on
the Flatbush as Guardians this Thursday
night lets show on Tiger pride go get
him Tigers roar the Flatbush Asgardians
is an amusing thought Easter Egg which
shows that Thor and the Asgardians seem
to be quite popular on earth now we
already saw a curious reference to Thor
in the final movie in the shape of the
Korean church of Asgard and of course
Betty's go-get-'em Tigers is a nice
Easter Egg to MJ's go get em tiger which
he said to Peter Parker at the very end
of spider-man 2 there's another funny
segment called under the mask which
speculates on the real identity of
spider-man up next under the mask who is
spider-man spider-man I don't know who
he is but I have my suspicions it's a
mystery it always will be
Michelle has her suspicions which imply
she thinks it's someone she knows and at
the end of the movie she joked that she
thought Peter was hiding something so
I'm thinking this is quite likely a
tease to her uncovering Peters secret
identity in the sequel today so Kobe in
relief lunch enjoy a $5 all-you-can-eat
paprikash buffet all proceeds go to
charity this clip gives us two tasty
callbacks to MCU movies first of all
it's clear that there are ongoing
efforts to raise money to help sokovia
after the destructive events of Avengers
age of Ultron and secondly the paprikash
meal the school canteen is serving is a
nice nod to the dish that vision
prepared for Wonder in Captain America
Civil War and remember that Wanda
herself also originates from sokovia
happy hogan gets a short comedic deleted
scene where he calls up his mother after
he's finished arranging the move of
Avengers tech 2 the team's new facility
hey MA yeah it's Harold yeah it's done
yeah Tony trusted me and I took care of
it me yeah mom me is that so hard to
believe
that I could accomplish something I'll
call you back it looks like this
cutscene is trying to build up some
backstory for happy in the MCU showing
how he feels he has to prove himself to
his mum and while it's humorous I can
understand why this moment was probably
cut for time after all it doesn't add an
awful lot and may have even undercut the
drama of the fight scene going on in the
cargo plane at the same time there are
few other deleted scenes which although
Maudsley interesting will likely trim to
avoid padding out the final cut which
was already over two hours one is an
additional scene where Peters classmates
try to convince him to go to the
academic decathlon you can't be able to
week before nationals we don't have
anyone as strong as in physics you have
flash you got me everyone prefers pizza
yeah look they're not gonna do a physics
challenge two years in a row
I'm glad this was cursed as it doesn't
add much compared to the better pace
scene of the Decathlon team practicing
which introduced each of Peters
classmates in a much funnier more
interesting way other scenes cut to trim
the fat include various moments of
spider-man running and swinging around
Brooklyn the scene of Adrian Toomes on
the phone to his daughter and a scene of
Peter and Ned doing their secret
handshake on the street again Captain
America's PSAs was something a lot of
fans enjoyed and there are many more
which aren't on the digital release but
which are expected on the blu-ray
including one about brushing your teeth
in the meantime there's an additional
one about hot lunches that wasn't
included in the movie but is on the
blooper reel I am Captain America
whether you're a student or a soldier
there's one thing that will always give
you an edge a hot lunch now what do you
think of those deleted scenes and do you
wish any had been included in the film
and which are the upcoming Marvel movies
you most excited about let me know what
you think in the comments section and
don't forget to subscribe for a chance
to win an awesome spider-man Funko pop
I'll be announcing the winner in an
upcoming video so do hit the bell to get
notifications for all my new videos your
support is hugely appreciated as always
and if you enjoyed this make sure you
leave a like and check out more of my
marble and deleted scene videos right
here congratulations to the three
winners of my kings my merch giveaway
who are on the screen now if that's you
make sure you contact me so I can get
your details to send you the prize
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers